le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
parfois des situations familiales
compliquées ne permettent pas
l'éducation et l'épanouissement des
enfants
ces jeunes ont besoin d'une prise en
charge d'une protection et d'un foyer
réconfortant ce sont les assistants
familiaux qui vont accueillir chez eux
ceux qui en ont besoin
agréée par le département ces personnes
font preuve de pédagogie et de dévotion
pour aider au mieux les jeunes quel
accueil à saint denis
rencontre avec pascale assistante
familiale depuis six ans
[Musique]
7h du matin réveil tout en douceur chez
pascal benjamin tu veux croire au matin
du déjeuner comme dans la plupart des
familles c'est lait et céréales pour
l'enfant de la maison mais benjamin ne
vite ici que depuis un mois
pascal n'est pas sa mère elle est
assistante familiale et je commence à le
connaître et lui aussi il a pris ses
repères ses marques ici à la maison ça
va c'est bon c'est pas très chaud le
lait un mois à s'apprivoiser
mutuellement et si les débuts ne sont
pas toujours facile pascal à sa petite
astuce pour adoucir les coeurs faut
avoir plein plein plein d'idées pour
amener ces enfants-là à voile à être
bien être tranquille va être apaisées
surtout au départ il est court et
derrière les poules avec lui avec des
galets et aujourd'hui s'en occupe donc
voilà il ya un grand pas bella rentrée
tout à leur compte et laurence fin oui
alors entre place par le haut point
[Musique]
après le rituel des poules c'est avec
patience et douceur que pascal prépare
son petit protégé pour l'école ça paraît
rituel si la passer au goûter
benjamin il était un peu indisciplinés
en bus du coup on l'a privée de bus est
bon comme je vois qu'il est sage
maintenant je pense qu'il va reprendre
le bus bientôt
une fois benjamin à l'école pascal peut
s'accorder un moment de répit
elle est assistante familiale depuis six
ans qui m'a amené c'était bon bah le
fait que je cherchais du travail
premièrement parce que j'étais dans une
situation pas très confortable on va
dire niveau finances c'était au moment
aussi au département recruter donc j'ai
postulé très vite l'instinct maternel a
transformé ce hasard en évidence on
qu'on place un peu les parents parce que
pour x raisons les parents ne peuvent
plus s'en occuper
donc nous on prend le relais 1 là par
exemple j'ai doit aller voir le club de
boxe pour lui le petit livret fabas boxe
fib un appareil si un enfant est malade
à l'école un peu moi qui me déplace pour
aller le chercher allaient l'emmener
chez le médecin tous qu'une maman fait
un une mère de substitution mais aussi
une mère provisoire le but c'est de les
réintégrer dans leurs familles le but
c'est ça donc on parle de des familles
avec eux s'il ya des liens à faire on le
fait avec eux on les amène un a
rencontré les familles
j'en ai un de 19 ans qu'est parti ce
samedi samedi dernier il avait 13 ans et
demi quand il est arrivé il est parti à
19 ans des situations parfois déchirante
qu'il faut pouvoir gérer
c'est pour cela que le département a mis
en place des formations afin
d'accompagner les assistants familiaux
est ce que vous pensez qu'on pourrait
aborder sa l'ordre un groupe d'analystes
de pratique on essaye de faire trois à
quatre fois par an comme ça ça nous
permet de voir un petit peu les accueils
des autres collègues
et puis si on a rencontré le même même
accueil même type d'accueil dont on peut
en parler on peut donner des idées et
puis nous préférons professionnel est là
aussi pour nous aiguiller 1 pour nous
elle nous aide à nous professionnaliser
c'est déjà très lourd elle n'est pas
tout seul on se dit qu'on n'est pas tout
seul dans ces cas pour faire ce métier
et de se voir un petit peu comme
centraux collègues - ça m'apaise book
quels sont les besoins des enfants je
pense que ça vous savez les assistants
familiaux sont agréées par le conseil
départemental
il dispose d'un salaires et d'indemnités
liées à leur activité
l'assistant familial assure une mission
de la protection de l'enfance et c'est
un vrai métier c'est pas facile d'avoir
à gérer l'entretien l'éducation d'un
enfant d'assurer la rentrée scolaire les
assistants familiaux font un travail non
seulement d'importance mais aussi j'ai
envie de dire un travail d'amour en
assurant du lien social et du lien
familial pour les enfants de l'aide
sociale à l'enfance
si aujourd'hui les enfants de pascal
sont adultes il lui reste beaucoup de
tendresse à partager pour ceux qui en
ont le plus besoin
on en donne autant qu'on en reçoit c'est
vraiment enrichissant et on va dire que
j'ai trouvé ma voie
professionnellement c'est ce que
j'avais envie de faire et j'ai quand on
m'a embauché j'ai dit voilà c'est ma
voix et j'adore ce métier
[Musique]
un assistant familial est un
professionnel qui accueille un à trois
mineurs ou majeurs de moins de 21 ans
il doit présenter des qualités humaines
éducative une grande disponibilité et
des conditions de logement adapté
il est agréé par le département après
des entretiens et un stage préparatoire
à la réunion on dénombre près de 850
assistants familiaux qui accueille plus
de 1800 enfants
pour plus d'informations ou pour devenir
assistant familial
vous pouvez appeler au 02 162 90 33 24
au 02 62 90 33 40 ou consulter le site
du département au www.cn.ca 4 point fr
[Musique]